FIRST THE RESISTANCE FOR
AMERICA'S FAILURE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
KIM JONG-UN IS THREATENING TO
CANCEL THE JUNE 12th PEACE
SUMMIT.
DEMOCRATS REJOICED.
YES, THEY DID THE NORTH KOREA
DICTATOR'S FOREIGN MINISTER IS
TAKING ISSUE WITH U.S. MILITARY
EXERCISES UNDER WAY WITH SOUTH
KOREA.
EVEN THOUGH THESE ARE EXERCISES
THAT ARE CONDUCTED EVERY SINGLE
YEAR.
THE NORTH KOREANS ARE AGITATED
THAT THE HERMIT KINGDOM SHOULD
COMMIT TO A COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION SIMILAR TO
LIBYA IN 2004.
THAT REALLY SET THE NORTH KOREA
FOREIGN MINISTER OFF.
HE SAID IT'S A MANIFESTATION OF
A SINISTER MOVE TO IMPOSE ON OUR
DIGNIFY
DIGNIIE
DIGNIIED
DIGNIIED S
DIGNIIED STA
DIGNIIED STATE
DIGNIIED STATE T
DIGNIIED STATE THE
DIGNIIED STATE THE DE
DIGNIIED STATE THE DEST
DIGNIIED STATE THE DESTIN
DIGNIIED STATE THE DESTINY:
WELL, NORTH KOREA VACILLATION
AND THE BAIT AND SWITCH ROUTINE
IS TYPICAL.
IT WAS PROBABLY EXPECTED BY THE
TRUMP TEAM.
WHAT I SAW AND HEARD WHEN I WOKE
UP THIS MORNING WAS EVEN MORE
DISTURBING THAN WHAT NORTH KOREA
IS PULLING HERE.
AMERICAN COMMENTATORS WEARING
THEIR, "SEE I TOLD YOU SO"
SMIRKS, REVELING IN WHAT COULD
BE BAD NEWS FOR THEIR OWN
COUNTRY.
THEY WERE DANCING ON THE GRAVE
OF THE PEACE SUMMIT.
FOR THE SOLE REASON IT WOULD
EMBARRASS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU LOOK AT HISTORY, YOU
WOULD BE A LITTLE MORE CAREFUL
ABOUT BEING BRAGGING.
>> I MEAN THIS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS AN ARK VERSION.
HE IS ALLERGIC TO COMPLEXITY AND
A
ALLERGIC TO HISTORY.
>> THEY ARE RATTLING HIS CAGE.
>> I THINK THERE WAS A TENDENCY
FROM THE PRESIDENT TO BE DOING
AN END ZONE DANCE IN
ANTICIPATION OF HAVING SCORED
SOMETHING.
HE IS DOING THE END ZONE DANCE
ON HIS OWN 20 YARDLINE.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK HE EVER
PAID FOOTBALL.
THE FORMER FBI CHIEF SAID THIS
TURN OF EVENTS IS UNSURPRISING,
SINCE DONALD TRUMP SEEMS
ENAMORED WITH A FAIR, AIM, READY
POLICY THAT IS:
IT SOUND LIKE THE CIA.
MAYBE IN THE MEDIA WERE NOT SO
UPSET WITH ALL THINGS STORMY OR
RUSSIAN COLLUSION THEORIES,
MAYBE THEY COULD SEE HOW PETTY
AND UN-AMERICAN THEY SEEMED
TODAY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF DOING SOMETHING
PROFOUNDLY GOOD FOR THE UNITED
STATES AND FOR OUR ALLIES
THROUGHOUT ASIA.
ACHIEVING PEACE AND BRINGING
NORTH KOREA OUT OF THE DARK AGES
OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
THAT'S A CRITICAL OBJECTIVE.
LET'S NOT FORGET, TRUMP HAS
ALREADY DONE THE UNEXPECTED.
HE HELPED LIBERATE AMERICAN
HOSTAGES FROM NORTH KOREA'S
HANDS AND OPENED UP THE
POSSIBILITY FOR REAL PEACE.
HE CHANGED THE DYNAMIC.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TODAY SAID
THEY HAVE NO OFFICIAL INDICATION
FROM NORTH KOREA THAT THE SUMMIT
IS OFF AND RIGHT NOW THE
PRESIDENT IS PLANNING TO BE
THERE.
EVERY UNITED STATES CITIZEN
SHOULD WANT THE SUMMIT BETWEEN
TRUMP AND KIM JONG-UN TO HAPPEN.
OF COURSE, FOR IT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
THE LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE AT
STAKE HERE.
ENDING THE POSSIBILITY OF
THERMO-NUCLEAR WAR, THAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN SCORING CHEAP